So where are we nailing?
We're, we're.
We're sort of in long ago.
We also in the little house.
We are in the little house.
Yeah. Right now.
Is this insane for you?
It is. It's incredible.
You're doing interviews all day.
It's been crazy busy already,
but this is so real for us to be here
and for all the hard work finally, like, happen.
I, I don't know that when we started this, uh,
we really got serious about this a couple of years ago,
and any of us could have imagined. Yeah.
Was going to become what you're seeing. Yeah.
And
what do you think you should say to all the people that can't be here?
Well, I'm sorry you're not all here.
We'd love it if you all could get here,
but there wouldn't be room for all of you here,
so we are going to share tons of pictures.
We're so grateful for the love that people have the show,
and it's that love that really inspired the creation of all.
So really, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.